okay we're good to start so I'd like to
um welcome everyone to the public
portion of the finance and projects
committee
um for today
um so the agenda obviously is in front
of everyone so any apologies other than
the two I have here being Nigel in Ellen
could I have a mover and a second or for
those apologies to proceed thanks snobby
thanks Leslie always in favor
aye
carried okay so any Declarations of
interest in relation to this agenda
no
okay
um so then the public forum portion of
this which is in effect the minutes from
the financing projects committee meeting
held on the 22nd of November
um
happy to move those Mr chair yes thank
you
thanks Barry so movement is the second
of Barry
okay so
um
yeah sorry put that motion to receive
the minutes
agreed all those in favor aye carried
okay we'll review the minutes or accept
everyone's read those moments any
amendments or comments in relation to
those moments
good okay so now I need to move to
public excluded so
can I have someone
I'll move to Second thanks Trish and
second Leslie
motion
all those in favor
Kerry
yeah